[Musica]
Allora all'improvviso qualche settimana
fa la politica internazionale è volata
sopra le nuvole è successo quando gli
Stati Uniti Pooh hanno abbattuto un
pallone aerostatico cinese acuta
accusando Pechino di averlo utilizzato
per scopi di spionaggio nei giorni
successivi altri palloni arrestati ci
sono stati abbattuti e i giornali si
sono riempiti di dettagli su come si
recuperano dei detriti che sono caduti
dal cielo e anche della differenza tra
palloni spia e satelliti spia che no non
sono la stessa cosa ho scoperto appunto
in quei giorni ora Questi elementi hanno
fisiologicamente perso di fascino
mediatico nei giorni successivi Ma
questo quello che è successo ci permette
di parlare e ci ha ricordato che la
politica non si fa solo nel parlamento
da parte dei governi ma anche tra i
pianeti Allora oggi vi porto in viaggio
nello spazio partiamo insieme alla
scoperta della politica extraterrestre e
partiamo da da una fascia in realtà
abbastanza vicino a noi che è distante
tra i 15 e i 45 km e si chiama Forgotten
Space lo spazio dimenticato Ed è proprio
lo spazio in cui volano i palloni
aerostatici che hanno creato così tanta
tensione tra Stati Uniti e Cina ora vi
sembra forse tanto distante tra di noi
ma non così tanto se pensiamo che gli
aerei che prendiamo di solito volano a
circa 12 km di distanza dalla terra
Quindi proprio appena sotto i palloni
aerostatici
dal Forgotten Space che poi si chiama
anche miare Space perché è il più vicino
a noi Near in inglese vuol dire vicino
continuiamo a salire saliamo velocemente
e arriviamo a 300 chilometri di distanza
dalla terra Questo è uno spazio
trafficatissimo perché qui che volano i
satelliti orbitano i satelliti che
possono essere spesso utilizzati per la
geolocalizzazione per esempio quando
chiamate un Uber o lo utilizzate su
WhatsApp ma anche per altri motivi come
per esempio fini di spionaggio i
satelliti hanno dei delle attrezzature
che permettono di fare delle rilevazioni
molto accurate fotografie
dettagliatissime in alcuni casi
addirittura verificare valutare e
intercettare il lancio di missili anche
qui la politica ci aiuta con un esempio
molto pratico successo recentemente
questi satelliti nei mesi che hanno
preceduto l'invasione della Russia in
Ucraina hanno proprio permesso di
monitorare questo è stato fatto
dall'intelligenza americana come alcune
truppe russe si stessero avvicinando al
confine ucraino e quindi da un certo
punto di vista preparare anche i paesi
alleati a un possibile conflitto
questi satelliti spesso parliamo no di
intelligence americana come se fosse la
migliore al mondo è davvero proprio
perché gli Stati Uniti Controllano la
maggior parte di questi satelliti che
sono tantissimi tant'è che sono
aumentati di 17 volte in numero negli
ultimi 10 anni Ora io lo so cosa state
pensando state pensando ma se ci sono
così tanti satelliti e funzionano così
bene ma perché la Cina ha utilizzato un
pallone aerostatico che sembrava uscito
da un film di inizio Novecento beh le
ragioni sono moltissime e la prima è
abbastanza semplice un pallone gonfiato
costa molto meno di un satellite Ma se
ne sono ipotizzate anche scoprire la
prima per esempio è che l'utilizzo di
questi palloni permetta di seguire con
molto più dettaglio e più da vicino il
movimento di degli obiettivi che si
muovono sulla terra poi come sempre in
politica si è fatto anche un po' di
retroscena e quindi si è parlato sui
giornali proprio del fatto che la Cina
volesse stuzzicare gli Stati Uniti farsi
vedere per indispettirle ora mettiamo
per un attimo da parte i retroscena
politici e continuiamo nel nostro
viaggio e vogliamo ancora più su a 400
chilometri di distanza dalla terra dove
c'è la stazione spaziale internazionale
la stazione spaziale internazionale è
una sorta di enorme laboratorio
orbitante dove a turno degli Astronauti
di diversi paesi Fanno esperimenti
studiano la vita nello spazio per poi
permetterci di capire meglio anche
quella che facciamo sulla terra
la stazione spaziale internazionale ci
permette di valutare di raccontare due
caratteristiche un po' particolari di
quando si fa politica nello spazio la
prima caratteristica è molto concreta
mandare navicelle persone e attrezzature
nello spazio costa tantissimo Ecco cosa
facciamo noi quando vogliamo una cosa
che non ci possiamo permettere
Uniamo le forze facciamo cassa comune e
questo è quello che fanno i paesi quando
si tratta della Stazione Spaziale
internazionale che è finanziata da un
numero ampio di paesi in particolare da
l'Unione Europea dagli Stati Uniti dalla
Russia dalla Canada dal Giappone
Cosa vuol dire questo che
obiettivamente ci sono tantissime
finanziamenti che sono collegati quindi
i paesi devono lentamente mettere dei
fondi e decidere quanto allocare abbiamo
anche parlato del collegamento tra
Russia e Stati Uniti che finanziano lo
stesso tipo di investimento e questo
complica molto le cose Ora l'agenzia
spaziale italiana che è controllata dal
governo
finanzia la stazione spaziale europea
che a sua volta finanzia quella
internazionale ed è il terzo
contributore dopo Francia Germania
Questa è una proporzione che rispecchia
in modo lineare la dimensione della
nostra economia proprio
proporzionalmente la dimensione nostra
economia ora la collaborazione
internazionale non è limitata a questa
stazione internazionale tant'è che Lesa
per esempio ha scritto degli accordi
anche con la Cina che ha lanciato una
sua stazione spaziale internazionale
alla fine del 2022 collaborare quando
parliamo di politica nello spazio è una
cosa molto pratica noi tutti conosciamo
per fama Samantha cristoforetti che la
più famosa astronauta italiana che
addirittura per un periodo aveva
iniziato a studiare mandarino ed era
anche andata in Cina per fare degli
allenamenti con i colleghi cinesi
la collaborazione nella politica
internazionale È una cosa molto pratica
anche per un altro motivo Nel senso che
riguarda tutti noi allo stesso modo a
prescindere dal nostro paese dalle
nostre idee politiche
guarda basta un esempio molto pratico
per capire perché Se un asteroide
colpisce la terra e la distrugge il
problema riguarda tutti noi è proprio
nello stesso modo ed è per questo che
studiare Come proteggerci quindi una
difesa planetaria comune è interesse di
tutti e collaborare
permette di migliorare le possibilità di
farlo al meglio quindi la politica
internazionale è protetta da una sorta
di tregua planetaria
è chiaro che però anche questa sorta di
tregua planetaria stata messa in
discussione messa in dubbio
dall'invasione dell'Ucraina che ha reso
impossibile per gli Stati Uniti per i
paesi occidentali continuare a
collaborare a investire in progetti
comuni
anche finanziati dalla Russia proprio
nello stesso periodo in cui cercavano
sulla terra di tagliare tutti i legami e
i collegamenti con le sanzioni Quindi al
momento ci troviamo un po' come ai tempi
della guerra fredda quando Stati Uniti e
Russia facevano a gara per la conquista
della luna e lo spazio è diviso in due
in una sorta diciamo di binomio
ora dai 400 km di distanza dalla terra
dove siamo arrivati iniziamo il nostro
viaggio per tornare indietro
salutiamo la fase dei satelliti che dove
c'è molto traffico vediamo tra i 15 e 45
km di distanza dalla terra i palloni
aerostatici molti di questi sono usati
davvero per fini metereologici e
torniamo qui sulla terra Ora forse dopo
aver considerato per un attimo la
possibilità che veniamo colpiti da un
asteroide aver parlato dei retroscena
sul perché un pallone era statico sia
stato abbattuto mi sembrerà un dettaglio
non necessario un po' come quando
guardiamo il dito e non vediamo la luna
per rimanere in tema ma in realtà
abbiamo fatto questo viaggio insieme per
parlare di un'altra caratteristica
importante della politica
c'è un motivo per cui appunto vi ho
accompagnato in questo viaggio Ed è per
portare la vostra attenzione
sull'importanza di collaborare tra Paesi
a prescindere dai propri confini oggi
abbiamo parlato di meteoriti di pianeti
di stazioni spaziali ma avremmo potuto
parlare di tantissimi altri argomenti
avremmo potuto parlare di cambiamento
climatico avremmo potuto parlare
dell'uso delle risorse limitate che
abbiamo sulla terra dall'energia ai
minerali perché alla fine la politica e
la Geopolitica quindi la politica
internazionale hanno un comune
denominatore per trovare una soluzione è
necessario collaborare
nel vostro sacchetto Io ho finito qui
però nel vostro sacchetto troverete una
matita c'è un motivo Quando negli anni
60 70 si è iniziato a fare questa gara
per la conquista dello Spazio
Russia e Stati Uniti hanno iniziato a
grattarsi il capo e dire Ma come è
possibile scrivere nello spazio dove non
c'è gravità e quindi no l'inchiostro
della penna si spostava e la fine Russia
hanno trovato una soluzione abbastanza
ingegnosa utilizzare le matite ed è per
questo che ve ne lascio una Grazie mille
[Applauso]